you must be hella
and for son of Odin really you don't
look like him perhaps we can come to an
arrangement you sound like him
Neal beg your pardon Neal
before your queen
I didn't think so not possible darling
you have no idea what's possible the
hell is the goddess of death and I've
had incredible fun playing there oh I've
missed this tell us the first female
villain that we've had in the Marvel
film and Kate has destroyed the idea of
your typical villain kneel before your
Queen working with Kate Blanchet I was
so excited to see what she was gonna do
hello as this insane off-kilter attitude
no like a smart boy how would you like a
job
I think the best villains are always
those that you kind of love and hate
what they do but you sort of understand
it there's a logic to it she wants to
come back home and be accepted and she
wants what says you're in my seat I
would love for someone else to rule but
it can't be you you're just the worst
some of the happiest times have been
beating people up I've really enjoyed us
like I don't speak today I can just
throw axes in - someone's got good
you
you